[Music]
hello
hi nice to meet you nice to meet you
what's your name megan what's your name
i'm arnie nice to meet you are you
feeling confident about your country
snacks
i'm very confident that that sounded
like a confident answer
very very confident i'm sure it'll be
better than the irish snacks but
if i'm honest with you i don't actually
know irish food
oh well so be quiet
uh right
[Music]
i went to ireland once this one time in
ireland
yeah let me guess you went to dublin you
went to temple bear
yeah and you got a guinness yes
that's usually how that story goes
should we start with old speckled hen
and then
yeah cheer the taste up with guinness
after
have a starter of all speckled hen
i might be the worst representative of
the uk
i've never joked i'll just
let's see how it goes cheers
it's not stopping okay
that's not bad
all i can taste is beer pong no that's a
regret that is
that that's really good yeah okay let's
do guinness
right so i used to think ireland was
attached to england at the
bottom which is really bad
[Laughter]
all right anyway schleider she's a bit
shocked when i had to get on a plane to
get there
wait but
why is it coming out
it's like creamy oh really well like
hard
no it's like oh nobody's coming out the
top swish it
oh what
mommy's got me out look
you have to oh sorry
did you see it stop though and then it
came out yeah
you have to like right yeah
all right it's not coming out again but
slap it
nice suck on it like suck the cat the
dummy thing um
yeah it's yeah i think i prefer it like
draft
yeah not canned i think i uh however
much i loved my trip to dublin
and i had some great memories yeah
brilliant or lack thereof
oh it was so good we had 16 boys in the
house it was so good
and someone's head went through a window
once but however
yeah however good the memories were
that's vile
i mean okay
[Music]
what's that that is my mom's childhood
that is a plain
digestive biscuit or like a rich tea
biscuit which is butter
yeah that looks interesting this
is a it's a crumpet dollar i see it
that's it
that's right
[Laughter]
that's pretty good it's better than the
crumpet um
i would argue but no i think you're
right
yeah i think your mum wins this round
oh it's i'm english
it's uk isn't it that's it i thought it
was scottish uk
oh i'm from the uk right yeah yeah
yeah that's what i was thinking oh wait
what's yours like a b-tech fanta
no this my friend is the nectar of the
gods right
right club orange is a rarity in this
country i can never find it and when i
do find it it's not the right one
club orange club orange okay yeah yeah
also taste of childhood in the pub right
which one should we go with first
all right we'll do iron brew first
island oh iron roof iron brew
okay i've never had iron brew actually
perfect
is this good so it's just
this is an experience for both of us
cheers cheers
that smells like diabetes man
oh that tastes like jager bombs what
jacobs you drink
cause you know it's like energy drink
stuff but it's actually it grows on you
doesn't it you know what i'd drink it if
i was hungover to be fair
i have heard of iron brew club orange
never heard of it
right this is beautiful um
[Laughter]
oh that's better than
banter we have a winner that's good
it is better really good
oh
i remember these they were like in the
back of my
brain somewhere so these
dentists love these they get loads of
money when you
bite them and you either break your
teeth or you need a fill-in right
so it's literally basically like an
orange hard-boiled suite
so when you when you have them in your
mouth for a long time the chocolate on
the inside
melts stop it
all right yeah go
oh sorry
is it another one no
all right are you ready put it in your
mouth right right
cheers one two three go
look at that ages oh my mouth is like
glued shut
oh my god clicking from these
too late
[Laughter]
it might not be glamorous oh yeah so you
want to go
yeah lovely really nice oh orange
chocolate
cheers
that's horrible i will say that yeah
that's horrible that's it no from me
eclair you know um
peanut butter the chocolate just doesn't
go reese's pieces peanut butter
chocolate does go
yeah it does it's a fact it doesn't
snickers oh yeah
i like sleeping yeah
yep thank you so much for
changing your mindset from the start of
today
i have walkers crisps um i think they're
quite british
i've seen gary lineker on the tv
eating a lot of these what have you got
well i have
potatoes not abbreviated potato actual
potato crisps and they're red in ireland
um so i'm not sure how my homeland will
feel about me eating
yellow potatoes but potatoes are bloody
taller isn't it
let's start with walkers okay okay
see good packet solid british
manufacturing
you ready one two three cheers yeah
isn't that just like good 11 o'clock in
the morning
it's like snack it just tastes like
a meal deal yeah exactly
onto the
oh cheap tables
[Music]
less flavor what
less flavor you will not ever eat these
on public transport you'll be kicked off
no that honestly i don't know if it's
because we had that first
and then this second but that has so
much more flavor
more like kick to it you sure you don't
have covered
[Laughter]
my winner i genuinely would agree with
you
but no it has to be walkers 100
[Music]
so i can build out the national anthem
irish won that
yeah we we went there with the snacks
yeah no well done
i think you deserve it just about i
actually get it now
i think like these are all the snacks
this is
i was just thinking like you know this
is snack wars yeah i get it
because i was thinking that you're just
comparing food and i just realized it's
snacks
not a
yeah sorry vanita i'm going to give it
to you
the flavour is there but it says it's a
monster munch
yeah it's not a monster and what does
this word gout mean other than
scout no goo peace
taste barbecue okay eat enough of them
you don't want to get gout
on the barbecue you're loving it isn't
it not particularly